si la política de quedarse en mexico
para esperar la decisión de asilo por
parte de eeuu tendrá que reinventarse
inmediatamente así lo determinó la corte
suprema de justicia argumentando primero
que bailén y su administración no
presentó los argumentos necesarios las
razones para acabar con esta política y
segundo que pues que no había argumentos
suficientes para argumentar que esta
política era discriminatoria era
arbitraria tres jueces liberales votaron
para pues rechazar esta política pero la
mayoría de los jueces de seis de nueve
jueces que son conservadores pues
apoyaron esta medida de pues re
implementar la política de quedarse en
méxico mientras los que aspiran al asilo
pues espero que tomen lleguen a una
decisión acá en eeuu las autoridades
vibratorias cristóbal entonces cuántas
personas y quienes se van a hacer
entonces afectados y qué pasará
en adelante con estas personas
esta fue una promesa de campaña que el
presidente bai ling y sophie que no
cumple y no cumple además en medio de un
nuevo contexto bastante agitado porque
las encuestas pues las tienen muy bajas
precisamente por lo que está pasando en
afganistán le doy una cifra cerca de 70
mil personas que estaban aplicando asilo
a través de la frontera entre méxico y
eeuu pues han tenido que regresar a
méxico y esperar allá la decisión de
asilo así que pues serán decenas de
miles de personas malas se verán
afectadas y pues lo que están diciendo
los demócratas es que lastimosamente
estas personas pues no van a poder
seguir esperando en méxico van a tener
que regresar a sus países a las amenazas
precisamente de las que estaban
escapando en sus países sin embargo los
republicanos pues están argumentando que
esto es una muy buena decisión la están
celebrando porque pues dicen que haber
acabado con esta política pues era
simplemente un incentivo para que muchas
más personas a través de la frontera
entre méxico y estados unidos llegarán a
eeuu de forma ilegal así que pues es una
victoria para los para donald trump y
una derrota para los demócratas